oui
auto winning dans les deux étapes mais
je ne suis pas une féministe lip service
féminisme je suis là pas de littérature
comment est ce que la littérature
africaine peut changer peut développer
l'afrique et développer le monde
donc comment est-ce que nous allons
parvenir cela donc l'afrique bouge
africa is rising l'état fries là
aujourd'hui c'est le meilleur moment
d'être un écrivain africain
les maisons d'édition nous courent après
les prix fusent de partout
on a pu citer quelques uns le kin
afrique en prime le project afrique en
sortie lundi de s'ignorer est le
fanatisme et le brunei university
africains pour trois et ainsi de suite
si je vais tous les sites et au stress
il sera demain matin on n'a pas de temps
à l'est nous avons une nouvelle vague
d'écrivains qui monte et qui monte donc
en plus de l'ancien va comme le google
chinois ou d aminata sow fall ou qu'elle
google nous avons la nouvelle vague est
composée débit avant de wana ou que
macao lice après tout moment dans notre
porte flambeau zucchi soi ou bien tu
boundou et moi même
nous sommes adulé et nous sommes chez
chuté à par l'occident malheureusement
si vous prenez un jeune personne dans la
rue au change et que vous le père de
littérature africaine
il vous aussi taira le nom de cet ancien
vague et donc moi je trouve que cela est
un problème si on se considère écrivains
africains suis moi même qui vous parle
je suis l'un des trains neufs mais l
écrivain afrique et en dessous de l'âge
de 40 ans précisons le a sur le
continent je pense qu'il ya un problème
quand personne ne me connaît ou
reconnaît aux caméras et autres le recul
donc de la littérature africaine se
situe circulant à trois niveaux
nous avons d'abord le manque de volonté
politique de nos dirigeants à leur faim
qu'on entend le plus souvent c'est que
la littérature ne nourrit pas son homme
ou sa femme 1
quand tu dois être tué devant on a
besoin de nourrir soutenir les femmes
que la littérature ne nourrit pas son
homme ou sa femme nous avons une
littérature qui est dynamique en juger
par les prix en juger par les maisons
d'édition qui veulent nous off
mais il faut bien connaître de l'espace
ou produit cette littérature qui est
dynamique et qui est engageante la
littérature peut très bien nourri son
nom on al'exemple 2
pichai moi je n'ai pas de problème avec
les fichiers d'un prêt le thème que
fustiger devrait aborde fabuleux on a
besoin d'eux d'érotisme de notre
littérature africaine
je suis en ce moment en train d'écrire
une nouvelle - roman qui va figurer les
routes is evil est un mets festifs sont
prêts c'est pas bien écrit si vous
l'avez si vous avez lu est ainsi un
texte aussi si vous ne l'avez pas lu
dombes havre bat nous avons besoin de
résidence de création pour écrivait
africains sur le continent africain
on a beaucoup de résidences de création
pour écrivains ailleurs mais on a besoin
d'être basés ici sur le continent pour
projet d eux est à l'écouté de notre
peuple et pour 38 ces idées là dans les
oeuvres que nous allons maintenant écrit
et bien sûr quand on va écrire c est
blanc
on a besoin qu'elle soit que le public
ait accès à ces oeuvres
nous avons eu le mouvement de la
négritude avec les tangos et autres qui
ont permis à la littérature africaine de
changer les choses un moment donné donc
nos littératures que nous espérons nous
dirigeants vont mettre des résidences de
création nos rêves nos deux là ont
besoin d'être a cédé par le public
on a besoin donc que nos dirigeants nos
gouvernants supporte les initiatives
littéraire en côte d'ivoire si nous
avons livresque qui est une belle
initiative une rencontre pour les
amoureux du nifff
malheureusement livresque a besoin
d'être implémenter un peu partout c'est
dj avec la fondation mtn et puis un
autre groupe nc assurances qui est pour
lier dj danseuses danseurs dans ce
mouvement espéraient bien que nos
dirigeants s'impliquent pour qu'on ait
l'ivresse
cette rencontre des amoureux dit niv
dans les villes comme korhogo ou bien
man ou de yamoussoukro extra extra
on a aussi besoin et de bibliothèques
nous avons quelques bibliothèques ici à
abidjan
mais abidjan s'il ya aussi abobo il ya
aussi yopougon il ya aussi comment ci
ayant des bibliothèques là bas ayant des
bibliothèques à yamoussoukro à bondoukou
amant à odienné on peux m'en passer tout
le talent et dans les maquis quand même
et puis si on appliquait par le syndrome
du quinze du moins ce syndrome le quai
du mot on doit fait de graines de
grandes budgétisation sinon c'est la
pagaille
sinon y'a draps et or il faut qu'on ait
des espaces ou que des coups que c'est
eux qu'on écrit là soient mis à la
disposition du public pour que le public
découvre cet amour pour le livre et
commence à lire sans avoir à payer
peut-être 4000 francs 5000 francs même
quelquefois dimitrov ou u19 dans une
librairie le soleil - sait combien le
deuxième point que donc oui nos
dirigeants résidence d'écrivain
bibliothèque six fois des initiatives
littéraire le deuxième point que je veux
soulever ce le manque d'engagement
politique de la nouvelle vague
d'écrivains africains
je suis quand je parle d'engagement
politique je ne parle pas de supporter
un tel ou un autre parti politique ou
bien un homme politique ou bien autre en
politique les enjeux auxquels nous
faisons face sont assez grands
possibilité une seule personne une seule
personne ne peut pas changer le monde
mais je pense de cet engagement que la
nouvelle génération doit avoir le fait
que la l'ancienne génération toujours
d'actualité c'est que cette ancienne
génération d'écrivains ce sont les
dirigeants africains qui les ont fait
baver oui ce sont les séries comme
phénomène african rights qui a fait
connaître les écrivains là au continent
africain
mais la différence en ces écrivains et
la nouvelle vague nous - c'est que ces
écrivains la connaissait les souffrances
et peut-être vivaient les souffrances de
son peuple de leurs peuples
il connaissait les aspirations de le
peuple aujourd'hui la nouvelle vague
d'écrivains africains veut dit qu'elle
n'est pas politique elle ne fait pas de
la politique ou bien qu'elle écrit qu
elle même je trouve cela choquant est
désolant un être humain et surtout un
écrivain africain de sucroît ne peut
affirmer qu'il ne fait pas de la
politique c'est lâche jeu je pense qu'au
lieu des crises sont des concepts comme
la folie des hommes
ce concept il veut que nous sommes tous
des cosmopolites et maintenant la
jeunesse africaine et cosmopolitan on
est peut-être née sur le continent nos
vies en paris londres et abidjan ou bien
abuja nous on revendique notre
africanité en occidentalisant le pacs ou
bien en étant là pis on a besoin de plus
qu'une api on a besoin ce n'est pas en
ayant les cheveux afro outre qu'on va
changer l'afrique en tant qu écrivain
africain
je pense qu'en tant que écrivait
africain on doit réaliser qu'il ya une
jeunesse africaine
une minorité qui est cosmopolitaine qui
n' a pas la majorité de la jeunesse
africaine est en train de mourir
pagaille de la mer méditerranée la
majorité de la jeunesse africaine est en
train de donner sa poitrine pour des
enjeux politiques elle ne maîtrise pas
la majorité des femmes à free de la
jeune femme africaine aujourd'hui un
train d'occuper des postes de
responsabilité mais elle fait face à des
lois absurdes sur le divorce par exemple
je lisais les délits d'habitude et
instantanée fait en côte d'ivoire par
exemple le gall peut tromper mille fois
mais si la femme qui fait sa une ce
foyer futur ou bien des lois sur l'eau
de succession en côte d'ivoire
unis
je pense que c'est à nous la nouvelle
génération
l'ancienne génération fait sa part le
régina yaou le walhalla liqing les
mariama bâ ont fait le pas
c'est à nous la nouvelle génération
d'utiliser l'âme que nous avons lu de
stylos pour être à l'écouté de notre
peuple est écrit vraiment pour notre
pôle et des clips notre ventre là je
fais on a besoin de se nourrir mais
quelquefois nourrisson ici la réflexion
précède l'action
le troisième point que je veux soulever
donc c'est que l'écrivain africain doit
vraiment écrit pour son peuple
dans quel français dans lequel anglais
écrivons nous adoptons le style d'un
français une idée critiquée éclaté pour
citer mais c'est yves coffi un français
qui y voit réaliser un seuil on décline
en nouchi pourquoi pas peut-être un uchi
soutenu mais on aura besoin de
dictionnaire pour on aura besoin d'un
dictionnaire pour qu'on nous explique
les mots comme critère ou bien le bruit
ou bien angie and light on a besoin
aussi décrit dans nos langues
nous avons ces exemples 1 % de la
population ici en côte d'ivoire est
analphabète et on veut écrit et on veut
se nourrit de nos écritures sérieux et
quand nous écrivons 16e blanc en nouchi
et un dans nos langues ivoiriennes
développant des stratégies de diffusion
de masse de ces livres on écrit des
livres
ce que j'ai remarqué on les a pris et on
la lance à cocody nous si on pense que
abidjan sur la côte d'ivoire combien
d'enfants vivent ne le sont pas à cocody
lensois le à youpougon biabou selon le
recensement selle avant que la halle
majorité de la population se trouve
la minorité bateau jeu là où la majorité
se trouve la majorité ne vient pas là la
minorité se trouve ou bien on pense que
la littérature fait pour les salons
huppés et les quartiers huppés ok
d'accord
ou bien parce que c'est à cocody et aux
deux plateaux est la riviera que le
pouvoir d'achat se trouve dont il fit le
pouvoir d'achat se trouvait là bas
pourquoi on dit que la littérature mais
pas son nom ou sa femme ce que c'est par
là bas que le pouvoir d'achat se trouve
alors ils pourront alors oui je pense
aussi que nous devons âme écrit dans nos
langues
mais nous n'avons pas encore de
politique d'alphabétisation dans nos
langues dont quand on les écrit
développement de stratégies jeu prey
danishi tout à l'heure mais toney dans
les formats peut-être mobile on va plus
faire du mob allemagne aura fait mobali
trade show mettra dans les formats
mobile cette littérature que nous
écrivons en hollande pour nos parents
pour nos amis autres qui ne peuvent pas
lire le français mettant dans les
formats audio
la raison pour laquelle a écrit dans nos
langues
premièrement oui ça fait business sens
si on veut être nourri de notre
littérature je sais que nous les
écrivains on aime penser à madonna mick
manière dont je vous dis on pense à 101
pensons ça peut faire ça peut faire de
l'argent
en effet harry chant ali l'écrivain
congolais inclut sa première oeuvre en
français quelques exemplaires vendus la
deuxième oeuvre kinshasa mathambo a fait
un tabac et il a été retenu pour le
projet africa trains neufs de cette
manière la deuxième raison pour laquelle
nous devons est cuit dans nos langues
c'est parce que nos l'angle représente
notre capitale et notre conscience
culture est dans un monde de plus en
plus global nous prenons l'exemple de
deux jeunes ivoiriens qui parlent
anglais qui parlent français équipe
allemande rinne ils ont vingt six ans
elle décide
de former une start up ils vont raconter
leurs partenaires chinois à shanghai et
avec le partenaire chinois mais cette
chaîne m6 chaînes ils s'entretiennent en
mangerait ils parlent de leurs études à
londres et il part de leurs vacances
passées à paris les discussions business
discrétion ça commence les gars chinois
il veut plus dans l'entreprise
les ivoiriens ne veulent pas facile
d'être contrôle de l'entreprise
et ça continue ça continue ils ont
besoin d'un petit break
vous parlez et les ivoiriens disent haut
et au gâchis loi mais c'est chez les
miss richie
écoutez on doit s'entretenir un court 18
à résister le côté on va rester là et
les ivoiriens maintenant se les garder
10 via un média mme diagne un oeil à
imad pas valoir moins pire qu'on
apprenne il n aura d honneur soit tu
combats auraient fait des offres
numériques au poker
la nouvelle met à nouveau en baisse mr
charles michel maintenant sont assis là
qu'est ce que le gala divers les
ivoiriens qui disent on vous verra
demain en on va les laisser reposer le
dire je pense que oui on va aller on va
les pensées mais cette chaîne m6 chaînes
vont se démener méfaits qu'elles n'en
vous parliez là donc si nous pensons que
nos langues sont minoritaires qui décide
de la majorité d'une langue qui décide
de la minorité d'une langue pensons dans
un monde de plus en plus global nous
avons besoin de notre capitale
culturelle
ce capital qui fait que oui on parle
français anglais marine mais aussi notre
langue que les autres ne parle pas parce
que ce sont des langues minorité
c'est notre conscience culturelle
poussette de ziv aux aléas de s'asseoir
et de pouvoir dix ans ya coups bas que
ce que les gars là raconte ce sont des
âneries
je ne l'ont pas s'asseoir ici pour
donner notre compagnie on va aller voir
quelqu'un d'autre
et puis ovale d'idées mais merci mais
non merci
en tant que écrivains africains la
nouvelle génération d'écrivains
africains c'est à nous de traduit ce que
notre peuple entend par définition de
développement ont parlé développement
auch à droite l'afrique bouge africa is
rising et moi je le dis tout le temps
qu'on des africains jeudi la titraille
the reading sarrail sagesse mais un
orage jamais le droit à un pipeau en
tant qu écrivain africain
soyons à l'écouté de notre peuple pour
entendre ce qu'ils pour pour comprendre
époux traduit par des moyens adéquats
ceux qui comprennent pas développement
pour nous autres qui ne sont pas un
écrivain peut-être france on a investi
dans leurs capitales culturelles qui
sont nos langues pensent aussi porter
des initiatives littéraire c'est comme
cela qu'on arrivera à changer notre pays
à changer l'afrique à changer le regard
du monde fis l'afrique et à changer le
monde
merci